[Music]
all right what's up everybody we are
back with another cooking video and I
know it has been a long time since I
made a cooking video this is actually
the first time I'm making one in the new
house not that the videos gonna show off
my kitchen too much now it's a pretty
simple recipe - we're not gonna be doing
a whole lot but yeah what we're making
the day is a Durrell's Cubano hope I'm
saying that right but it's Cuban rice
this dish is kind of mind-blowing in how
it came to me I grew up with my mom's
cooking right she makes food she makes
Chinese food mostly but she also made
this dish I grew up on a bar thought it
was Chinese food and I was like oh yeah
it's the tomato sauce over rice with a
fried egg
my mom used to like to put a slice of
ham in there as well but when TIFF and I
went to our honeymoon in Barcelona in
Spain we came across this dish and a
hole in the wall mom-and-pop place and
that we ordered it and when it came out
I was on my own but I was like this is
literally what my mom makes my mom made
Spanish roots with me or Cuban food and
that's the the mind-blowing part when
you search it on an Internet I've found
that some people claim that it's from
Spain some people claim it's from Cuba
and yet Spanish people call it the Cuban
rice and I don't know Peruvians have
something similar and in the Philippines
or something similar and somehow my mom
also made it not quite sure how it all
figures together let's just say it's
Cuban because the name is annals Cubano
and no I'm not gonna make a traditional
version of this I'm putting my own twist
to it because my mom put a twist to it
the way we make it as more of a Chinese
fusion component to it but even then
I've kind of took what my mom made and
kind of
little twist to imma show you my version
of Admiral's Cubano or you can say eros
a la Cuba nah my Spanish is bad all
right so first up we're gonna use six
Tomatoes six roma tomatoes I'm sure you
can use any tomato we need an onion
well technically half an onion we need
three garlic cloves 1/2 a teaspoon of
red pepper flakes we also need a little
stub of ginger salt and pepper to taste
and that's it super super simple I even
have an egg laid out so it started there
but super super simple that's all it is
all right so first thing we're gonna do
is take the roll put tomatoes it's all
six of them we're gonna chop them up
coarsely we don't need a like dice them
up too much the way my mom used to make
it was to keep it in chunks and then let
the cooking process kind of like
dissolve it into a stew don't you spend
too much time on it after that we're
gonna chop up the onion we're gonna only
use half of it say the other half for
another dish I don't know don't waste
onions this one you want to spend the
time to kind of cut it a little more
finer because the onions don't break up
as easily as tomatoes do when you stew
it and then take our garlic smash them
and then you what you want to do is just
burst the the fibers open so that and
cook with it the flavor comes down and
now we're not gonna dice up the garlic
cuz we're actually gonna be scooping the
garlic out once we're done cooking same
thing goes with the ginger we're gonna
smash it and open up the fiber so we can
release the aromas of it but we're not
gonna be dicing it and we're not gonna
be consuming the ginger either it's just
for flavors and aroma so now we're gonna
light up the stove heat up the pan to
drizzle a little bit of oil into the pan
once it's heated up we're gonna toss in
the garlic and the ginger and the red
pepper flakes our aromatics and we're
gonna saute that for about a minute to
sweat out the flavors and the aromas and
then from there we're gonna throw in our
onions don't find the chunks of ginger
and garlic to maximize their aromatics
I'll leave it in there and let it stew
altogether and I'll take out the ginger
and garlic before we serve it because
we're not gonna eat
ginger and garlic and we're gonna saute
the onions to get it to look translucent
and it's gonna start smelling really
good and these are the all the aromatics
working together side by side
simultaneously once you got those
flavors melded together we're gonna add
in our chopped tomatoes and then we want
to saute that for a little bit for about
maybe two minutes make sure to keep
moving her around we don't want it to
burn and from here we can add salt and
pepper to taste next we're add 1
tablespoon of sugar anytime you're
working with tomatoes and especially
when you're stewing tomatoes into like a
sauce or some sort you definitely want
to use sugar sugar is the thing that's
gonna combat that Tang enos that
Tomatoes has and sometimes it can get
too tomato week and about five minutes
later on medium-high heat you want to
add in one cup of water
and once you add that one cup of water
we're gonna bring it back up to a boil
and once it hits that boiling
temperature drop the temperature down to
low on your stove and cover and stew I
usually like to do it for about 15
minutes and in that 15 minutes you want
all the tomato chunks to break down as
much as possible and that's literally
the recipe because there are four
components the egg we're gonna just fry
it in a pan and the rice you well I
guess I can make a rice video too but
this isn't at that video hopefully you
know how to make rice damn I feel like
I'm missing something but I guess is
assessable alright so while your tomato
sauce is doing we re going to start the
fried egg first step in frying an egg
you want to heat up the pan and just a
little bit of oil in there and let that
heat up and once it's up to temperature
crack an egg challenge you to do it with
one hand and I had no idea how long to
fry an egg for cuz I never time and you
just kind of will stare at the egg until
it gets all white and there's no it is
not clear anymore so once you have that
done turn off the heat on the fried eggs
and let it rest for a little bit I
suppose
go back to your stew and at this point I
like to smash all the tomatoes down well
one I don't like using a blender if you
don't mind cleaning a blender which I
hate you can dump this whole thing into
a food processor and blend it up and you
have a great sauce right there for me
I'm just
[ __ ] break down the Tomatoes even more
and then right before you serve it make
sure to pull out all the garlic pieces
and the ginger so yeah if you're using a
food processor I guess you would pull
out the ginger and garlic first and then
blend the reason why I like just
smashing Tomatoes too is I like they'll
have a little bit of bite from the sauce
too from the tomatoes and if you want
something to chew on it makes more fun
so once we have our egg fried and we
have our tomato stew done we are going
to plate our meal so we start off with
the plate of rice top that off with our
delicious tomato sauce and from there
we're gonna top it off with our fried
egg and while that we have Edel's
Cubano and yes we could stop right there
and say we're done cooking and that is
our meal but today we are gonna go one
step further and bam you're gonna add a
pork chop to this dish just because I
want that extra protein and it's just
balances it out technically you can get
fancy with it you can do whatever you
want my mom used to had ham to it I've
hear people add ground beef to this I
like adding a pork chop you can add a
salmon stay a chicken steak a steak the
possibilities are endless it's got to be
the best part about this dish
possibilities are endless top off the
pork chop with a little more sauce I
like to do the emerald bam-bam-bam with
some green onions some scallions add
rows Cubano with the KC chant woods you
should definitely check out this recipe
it is one of my favorites all-time
favorites growing up and even now it's a
favorite of Isaac fort if like we all
loved this dish it's super easy so
definitely give this a try I love how
you write directly into the yoke of my
fried egg and letting the yolk drip into
the rice and the tomato sauce and you
have this perfect combination of like
egg tomato and rice oh and then take a
bite of that pork chop out of this world
out of this world so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video
definitely give the recipe a try and if
you
my Instagram is a sham improv make sure
to take a photo of it post on Instagram
and tag me because I'd love to check out
your creations and let me know how you
liked it comment down below let me know
what I should make next I will see you
next time
[Music]